Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, mein Name ist Kapagann.
Ich bin hier aus Wiesnabendans tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anmelsgespräch führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mir was sagen.
Okay, gerne.
Bevor wir beide aktuelle Beschwerden, ich möchte ganz schnell an eine Frage ansichern.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißt es?
Mein Name ist Günther Lauch.
Günther Lauch.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachname und Vornamen bestraben?
Vorname ist Günther Gustav Yüder, Nordpol Theodor, Heinrich E. Milrich hat.
Nachname Lauch, Ludwig Anton, Nordpol C. Heinrich.
Okay, ich habe eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ludwig Anton, Nordpol C. Heinrich.
Okay, danke.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 47 Jahre alt.
47 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geworden?
Am 15.05.1975.
Okay.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 82 kg.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 78 kg.
78 kg.
Ja, danke schön.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Was für welche Werte haben Sie momentan, Herr Lauch?
Und zwar seit 3 Wochen habe ich starke Schmerzen.
Im Bereich meines Nackens.
Der in meinem Recht ist ein sehr starker Schmerz.
Ich habe einen Schmerz,
der in meinem Recht ist.
der in meinem rechten Arm zieht.
Genau, Schmerzen, Nackenschmerzen haben Sie und rechten an.
Der in den rechten Arm zieht, ja.
Genau, ja.
Bis in meinen Baumen.
Ja.
Okay.
In Nacken und Wichtag sind diese Schmerzen
auch eine Schmerzfälle von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und sehr starker Schmerz meint.
7, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Können Sie mit den Schmerzen beschreiben,
sind die Schmerzen drückend oder ziehend?
Ziehend.
Drückend und ziehend.
Okay.
Sie haben gestern,
dass Sie die Schmerzen in den rechten Arm ausstrahlen.
Ja.
Gibt es etwas,
dass die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja.
Wenn ich meinen Kopf nach rechts drehe,
es verstärkt,
dann kriege ich einen Kröbeln in meinen Daumen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie sich bewegen,
wenn ich meinen Kopf nach rechts drehe.
Genau.
Drehe, ja.
Ein bisschen Taubkreisgefühl haben Sie, ja.
Ansonsten,
haben Sie Taubkreisgefühl in der andere Bereich?
nein.
Missempfindung haben Sie?
Leiden Sie darunter?
Ja, es fühlt sich komisch an.
Taub, pelzig, komisch.
Okay.
Aber nicht dauernd,
sondern nur,
wenn ich meinen Kopf nach rechts drehen würde,
dann zieht es stärker,
und dann wird es Taub.
Taub.
Und Kröbeln auch haben Sie?
Ja, ein bisschen auch.
Kröbeln kann man auch sagen.
Kröbeln und Taubheit.
Genau.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass die Schmerzen bewegungsabhängig sind,
wenn sie drehen nach rechts.
Auch in der Ruhe.
Auch in der Ruhe, okay.
Also wenn ich nichts mache,
habe ich einen Schmerz seit drei Wochen,
der in meinen Arm reinzieht.
Und nur bei mehr Belastung
habe ich so ein Taubheitsgefühl,
Kröbeln in meinen Daumen.
Genau.
Okay.
Und ich habe etwas vergessen,
zu fragen.
Leiden Sie unter ...
Okay.
Haben Sie Fibre?
Fibre habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie nicht?
Und rusten Sie derzeit?
Nein.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Herzstorben,
Herzrasen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein.
Luftnot oder andere Symptomen?
Okay. Bauchschmerzen haben Sie?
Nein.
Okay. Hatten Sie in der letzten Zeit
einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall, nein.
Oder Verletzungen oder ein Sturz haben Sie gehabt?
Nein.
Okay.
In diesem Nakenbereich haben Sie keine Sturz.
Verletzungen haben Sie keine ...
Nicht gehalten.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter ...
Nageblichsteitigkeit?
Jetzt ... die letzte Zeit ein bisschen schon,
aber ... aber vorher nicht.
Okay. Wegen der Schmerzen eigentlich
haben Sie diese Nageblichsteitigkeit.
Okay.
Und leiden Sie unter ...
Duschfall oder Verstoffung?
Ähm ... auch nicht.
Okay. Wie ist die Appetit?
Ja.
Gut.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Nichts wesentliches.
Ja.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Haben Sie erbrochen oder ...
Nein. Keine Übelheit.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlachen oder Sturzgang?
Schmerzen oder so?
Nein.
Zum Beispiel müssen Sie in der Nacht ...
auf die Toilette gehen.
Nein, normal.
Okay.
Könnte es Ihnen noch etwas sein, was ...
wichtig sein könnte?
Was ist das?
Zusammenhang mit diesen Schmerzen,
zusammenhang mit diesen Beschwerden.
Ähm ...
Was ... was wichtig wäre?
Okay.
Ähm ...
Und ...
jetzt möchte ich ...
nun ein paar Fragen
zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte, Vorerkrankung ...
an sich stellen.
Was meint ihr an bestimmte Vorerkrankungen,
wichtige chronische Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was meint ihr mit chronischen Erkrankungen?
Äh ... Bluthoffdrück oder ...
Blutzuckerkrankheits
äh ...
oder ...
Hyper ... Hyper ... Hyper ...
oder ... Schultusüberfunktion.
Also, ich hatte ...
Schabe seit einem Jahr ...
Herzberührung.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, nicht gut ...
... geerrissen.
Ja ... Herzrhythmisch-Dörungen,
aber die mit ...
... Kamentgut ... äh ...
... erhält wurde.
Okay.
Was ist mit Kamentgut, wie man es übergehen kann?
Äh ...
Auch heißen, weil es ist Beta-Blocker,
hat der Haus hat es mir gesagt.
Mhm.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die Kamentgut heißen.
Oh ja.
In welcher Dosierung wissen Sie nicht, ja?
Äh ... 5 Milligramm.
5 Milligramm.
Und äh ...
Ich habe nicht gehört,
oder vielleicht mein ...
mein Tablet ist das Problem.
Ich kann ... kann ich nicht jetzt Sie ...
... so gut zuhören.
Wenn ich ... wenn mir das einfällt,
oder ich stuf nachher meine Frau ein
und die ...
kann mir dann sagen, was auch der Packung drauf ist.
Okay.
Okay, Beta-Blocker, 5 Milligramm,
äh ... ein und ... äh ...
wie viel Mal am Tag nehmen Sie ein?
Äh ... morgens und abends.
Morgens und abends und seit einem Jahr
... äh ... leiden Sie an einer ...
äh ... Herzlitz-Bestörung.
Bestörung, aber wie genau das ...
Okay.
Und äh ... weitere Erkrankungen
leiden Sie darunter?
Haben Sie oder?
Nicht, dass ich püste, nee, sonst ...
Nicht, dass ich ...
Ach, aber ...
auch kein Bluthoch drüberkrankungen,
keine Zuckerkrankungen, was Sie gesagt haben,
weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ja, das ist gut.
Okay, und äh ...
nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein oder bei Bedarf?
Bei Bedarf, ja,
hatte ich äh ... Ibuprofen eingedrungen
wegen dem Schmerzen.
Und Novalg ... Ibuprofen und Novalg.
Ibuprofen, wie viel Milligramm?
Äh ... Ibuprofen 600 Milligramm.
Okay.
Äh ... wie viel Mal ...
Darf ich fragen? Wie viel Mal ...
nehmen Sie ein?
Ähm ...
zu zwei oder dreimal am Tag,
nehme ich schon ein, bei Bedarf.
Okay.
Novalgien, Creme, nehmen Sie, oder?
Ne, Novalgien als ...
Tropfen.
Dann nehme ich so 30 Tropfen bei Bedarf ein.
Okay.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Ja. Lacken Schmerzen, okay.
Genau.
Äh ...
komme ich damit relativ gut zurecht.
Die Linden ...
Äh ... Siehst du, ist schon einmal operiert worden?
Oh ja, da, wo ich klein war.
An meinen ... Mandeln.
Mandeln, okay.
Wie ... äh ...
im Alte ... im Kinderalter, ja.
Ja, da war ich zehn Jahre alt.
Mhm.
Und ansonsten ... keine weitere Operationen, oder?
Äh ... sonst, ne.
Bis jetzt, Gott sei Dank, nicht.
Okay, gut.
Äh, sind Sie gegenehmet etwas allergisch?
Allergisch, ja, damals, wo ich ...
operiert wurde, hat man mir ...
Penicillin gegeben und dagegen bin ich ...
Okay, Penicillin allergisch.
Wie erscheint diese Allergie bei Ihnen?
Äh ...
meine Mutter hat mir gesagt, ich hätte dann Atemnot ...
ich konnte nicht richtig atmen.
Ja, okay.
Und ... äh ... rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Gott sei Dank.
Sieht bei Ihnen Unverträglichkeit und welchen ...
Unverträglichkeit im Deckhand?
Unverträglichkeit, ja.
Ich hatte ...
... Dichlofenac ...
Dichlofenac ...
... hat ... Dichlofenac bekommen und ...
das hat meinen Magen ...
seitdem habe ich Magenprobleme ...
oder nicht seitdem, sondern ...
hatte ich ein Magenproblem gehabt.
Magenschmerzen und ...
wegen dieser Dichlofenac?
Ja, okay.
Magen ...
kein Dichlofenac ein.
Also auch Schmerzen und Durchfall hat es statt.
Okay.
Äh ... und ... möchte ich wieder ...
nochmals fragen, rauchen Sie?
Äh ... nein.
Nein, okay. Trink diese Alkohol?
Ja ...
bei Gelegener Träger ist das Wein.
Wein, okay.
Äh ... mitnehmen Sie ...
meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine medisicher Frage.
Ich muss Sie fragen, ob Sie Drogen nehmen.
Uhhh, Drogen.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie es geschrieben wird. Nein.
Ach, genau, okay.
Das ist noch mal eine Routinefrage,
deshalb wurde geschrieben, ja.
Äh ...
Okay, das ist gut.
Herr Lauf, ich möchte jetzt ...
zu Ihrer ... äh ...
etwas fragen.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder? Kinder? Ja, ich habe 2 Kinder.
Mhm.
Sind die Kinder gesund? Ja.
Gut.
Mit wem ...
wollen Sie zusammen?
Mit meiner Frau und ...
einem Kind.
Okay, gut.
Äh ... nehmen Ihre Eltern noch?
Ähm ... ja.
Okay.
Äh, haben Sie eine wichtige Erkrankung von denen ich wissen sollte?
Zum Beispiel ...
Blutzuckerkrankheit oder andere ...
Probleme, andere Krankheiten?
Bluthoff nimmt Medikamente ein wegen Bluthoff-Brugerkrankung.
Bluthoff-Brug.
Ja.
Und wegen Gichtanfälle
nimmt er auch Medikamente ein.
Mhm.
Und ...
ähm ...
meine Mutter ...
nimmt ... äh ... Schildrüsen-Tablette,
weil sie keine Schildrüse mehr hat.
Mhm.
Und ...
äh ... es ... äh ... nimmt Zuckertablette ein.
Tablett als Tablettenform.
Okay.
Genau.
Zuckertablette wegen ...
wie ist es Sie wegen welcher Typ ...
Zuckerkrankheit?
Äh, die ...
Okay.
Und ... ihre Mutter ... hat wegen ...
Schildrüsen ... äh ...
... welche ... äh ...
nehmen Medikamente ein wegen dieser ...
Schildrüsen-Sturungen.
Äh ... Schildrüsen-Überfunktion oder Unterfunktion?
Ist das ...
Ich würde mitnehmen, deswegen brauche ich Schildrüsen-Tabletten.
Okay, genau. Okay.
Das wurde entfernt, ja.
Genau.
Äh, wann wurde äh ... eine ...
Schildrüsenentfahrung ... äh ... durchgeführt?
Was ist die Schildrüsen-Mutter?
Ja, vor zehn Jahren ungefähr.
Okay, vor zehn Jahren.
Äh, was machen Sie ... oder ...
wo arbeiten Sie ... oder was machen Sie aus Berufsgericht?
Ich ... ich bin äh ...
wie nennt man das?
Ähm ... na ...
Programmierer im IT-Bereich traf ich, Programmierer.
Mhm.
Okay. Beide äh ... sind Sie zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Oh ja.
Wenn die mehr bezahlt wird, wäre ich noch zufriedener.
Okay.
Sie wissen ja, in Flachszeit, in Deutschland ist ja auch nicht ohne.
Die ... die Gehälter ...
wenn der mehr bezahlt würde, wäre es mir noch besser gehen.
Genau, ja, das ist natürlich ...
muss man ... Geld verdienen, äh ...
um gut zu leben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist schön ... das ist ... wichtig.
Ja, da ...
ein bisschen mehr Geld geben.
Genau, ja.
Äh ... und ich möchte ... äh ...
noch ein paar Frage an sich stellen.
Äh ... schreiben Sie Sport?
Sport.
Ich ... also ... ich fahre ...
regelmäßig Fahrrad.
Mhm. Das ist gut ...
für diese Gesundheit.
Äh ... und ... äh ...
sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Geimpft meinen Sie ... äh ... wegen Corona?
Wegen Corona und ... ja, das ist gut.
Und äh ... andere Grunderre ...
... alle Impfungen, die man als Kindheit und so weiter haben muss.
Und auch Tetanuschen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Äh ... haben Sie Stress?
Stress ... jetzt ja, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Ja, genau.
Können Sie damit umgehen?
Ja, aber wenn ich lange arbeite am Computer,
dann habe ich mehr Probleme.
Genau, ja.
Ja.
Ja, das verkeh ich, ja.
Wegen dieser arbeitsbedingten, haben wir Schmerzen.
Diese nacken Schmerzen natürlich sind ...
äh ... wichtig und Problem.
Für uns, ja.
Äh ... sind Sie in der letzten Zeit ...
äh ... im Ausland gewesen?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Können Sie gut schladen wegen dieser Schmerzen eigentlich?
Ja, wenn ich einschlafe, dann geht eigentlich schon.
Ja, ich kann gut schlafen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie keine Schmerzen haben, dann können Sie gut schlafen.
Aber wegen Schmerzen haben Sie ...
Es geht.
Es geht, okay, das ist gut.
Ja, ich nehme ... auf jeden und nur mal gehen
und dann kann ich einschlafen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Genau.
Äh ... Herr Lauf, äh ... ich habe von meiner Seite
alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestartet.
Äh ... ich würde kurz das Zusammenfass über Ihre Beschwerden ...
äh ... für Sie machen.
Äh, wenn Sie etwas ... äh ... hinschlafen möchten,
können Sie gerne äh ... hinschlafen machen.
Äh ... Sie haben seit drei Wochen einen Nackenschmerzen
und die Schmerzen strahlen in den Rechten an.
Äh ... und in den ... äh ... rechten Daumen.
Und äh ... dabei haben Sie auch äh ...
paar äh ... äh ...
Kräben und Taupaisgefühl ... äh ...
in den rechten ... äh Daumen, wenn Sie ... äh ...
Ihre ... ihre ... Kopfgräben ... äh ...
und die Schmerzen sind ... siehend ... äh ...
und äh ... äh ... ja ...
und dagegen nehmen Sie äh ...
Novalchintrofen und Ibokrofen ...
Fabulette ein.
Äh ... und möchten Sie etwas hinschlafen
oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Ja ... ähm ...
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Meine Frage ist, was habe ich denn, Herr Doktor?
Ja, äh ... Herr Lauf, ich möchte natürlich ...
Sie Ihnen erklären, wie wir vorgehen können.
Äh ... so heißt es, müssen Sie hier bei uns bleiben,
für weitere Untersuchungen und Behandlung.
Äh ... dann äh ... werde ich äh ...
Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen, dann äh ...
mit ... äh ... von Ihnen werde ich ... äh ...
Blut abnehmen ... und äh ... ein äh ... äh ...
MRT ... äh ... gegebenenfalls werde ich
für diesen naken Schmerzen äh ...
verlassen. Äh ... und mit dieser ...
Befunde und mit diesen Angaben ... äh ... werde ich ...
mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich so hinkommen
und sage hin, was zu tun ist und wie wir vorgehen können.
Hm ... okay.
Äh ... danke Ihnen, ja.
Danke auch.
Und bleiben Sie hier und nehmen Sie Klass im Warteverreich,
dann komme ich gleich.
Okay, danke.
Ja, miteschön.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen ... äh ... noch ... äh ...
äh ... unsere Kollegin hat äh ...
geschrieben, äh ... sind dich meistens
plötzlich oder langsam abgetreten?
Äh ...
ich glaube, das war ...
vor drei Wochen ... war es langsam ...
hat es begonnen gehabt, so ein, zwei Tage hat es gedauert,
bis es so stark war.
Leiden Sie auch unter Kraftlosigkeit ...
am linken ... oder äh ... rechten Arm?
Ne Kraftlosigkeit habe ich nicht.
Äh ... in Rechenfingern spüren Sie
ein Taubhausgefühl?
Daumen.
Daumen, ja.
Rechter Daumen.
Und ...
... oder link sind ...
Ich bin rechtshender.
Ab uns ... äh ...
... der Störung, herrschstörung, oder ...
... Schiebindelik ...
... aufschmerzen.
Ne.
Ab.
Hatten Sie früher ...
... enlische Bechverdung?
Wie bitte?
Hatten Sie früher ...
... enlische Bechverdung?
Ja, nicht so wie jetzt, nein.
Ich hatte nur mal ab und zu mal kriegt man so
Lackenschmerz, der ist ein, zwei Tage ist da dann weg.
Aber so wie jetzt hatte ich das noch nicht gehabt.
Hatten Sie in der Starzeit schweren, körperliche Belastung?
Äh ... nein.
Nichts Besonderes gewesen.
Äh ... 70-mal sind dauerhaft, oder ...
... in den Schulweise?
Ja, seit drei Wochen würde ich sagen dauerhaft.
Mal mehr oder weniger war dauerhaft.
Also ...
... Intensität ...
... Lackenschmerz, Belastung, Arbeit ...
... Medikamentatik ...
... aber ...
Ja, die Schmerz-Attacken sind so payse, aber die Schmerz sind ...
... dauerhaft.
Ja, die Tiktage.
Können wir als erstes die Schiebinde ...
... empfangen?
Ja.
Was ist denn jetzt, Herr Doktor, Kappa-Kann?
Kappa-Kann, ja.
Ja, können wir empfangen natürlich.
Okay, jetzt schon.
Herr Oberarist, guten Tag.
Hätten Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Jawohl, deswegen bin ich hier, bitte schön.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Herr Günther Lauf ...
... ist ...
... 47 Jahre alt und ...
... 82 Kilogramm schwer und 1,78 Meter groß.
Herr Günther Lauf hat sich bei uns ...
... heute bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen, drei Wochen ...
... Nackenschmerzen vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten ...
... und im Lager der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
In Schubweise schlimmer geworden.
Und die Schmerzintensität ist auch eine Schmerzkalauffonung 1 bis 10 bei 7.
Die Schmerzen sind ziehend.
Und der weiteren Berichter der Patient, ...
... dass die Schmerzen ...
... in rechten ...
... Hand, rechten Arm und rechten Daumen ausstrahlen würden.
Außerdem klagte der Patient über eine Taupais-Gerfüll,
wenn er ... sein ...
... sein Kopf drehe.
Taupais-Gerfüll und ...
... oder ...
... Rottieren.
Rottieren, genau, Rottieren.
Klagte er über ...
... Parastasy und Hip-Poastasy.
Und ...
... die Frage nach Ähnliche bei Schwalde in der Vergang- ...
... Vergangenheit, wo der Tern neint.
Ja, und ansonsten die westliche ...
... Vegart-Sanahmen sind unaufgänglich.
Der Patient, leider an einer ...
... Arithmie seit einem Jahr, ...
... dagegen nehmt der Patient 5 mg Betablöckel ein.
Und ...
... und wegen dieser Beschwerden nehmt der Patient ...
... Ibuprofen 600 mg dreimal am Tag ein.
Und Novalgin trofen 30 ...
... 30 Trofen Novalgin benötigt er ...
... wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Und ...
... als Operationen ...
... an Operationen ...
... leider Patient ...
... im Alter von 10 Jahren ...
... eine Tonselektomiert wurden.
Und bei der Patientin, bei der Patientin ...
... eine Penicillin-Aregie bekannt.
Die Penicillin-Aregie ausre sich ...
... wie Atemut bei den Patienten ...
... und eine Dichlofenac ...
... Unvertätigkeit ...
... sei bei der Patientin bekannt.
Und der Ausre sich ...
... Magen beschwerden und Diore ...
... bei den Patienten.
Und ...
... Herzlaus ...
... Tricke gelegen in Alkohol ...
... und ...
... Nikotinkusum ...
... und Drogenkursum wurden verneint.
Der Patient ...
... fahre Fahrrad ...
... als Sport ...
... und sei vorständig geïft.
Und ...
... die Frage nach ...
... Weise ins Ausland, in der letzten Zeit ...
... ins Ausland, wurde verneint.
Und der Patient ...
... leidet ...
... derzeit unter ...
... einer Stress ...
... aber könne er damit gut umgehen ...
... momentan.
Und der Patient sei verheiratet ...
... habe zwei gesunde Kinder ...
... und ...
... wohne mit seiner Frau ...
... und mit einem Kind zusammen.
Der Vater ...
... des Patienten leidet an einer Artillehypertonie ...
... und geht anfangen ...
... der noch lebe ...
... und die Mutter des Patienten ...
... leidet an einer ...
... Diabatsmilitus ...
... und ...
... sei eine Thyroidoktomie ...
... bei der Mutter durchgeführt worden ...
... deswegen ...
... nehme sie Medikamente wegen dieser Thyroidoktomie.
... Thyroidoktomie vor zehn Jahren.
Und der Patient sei ...
... programmier ...
... in einem IT-Bereich ...
... und arbeitet in einem Computer ...
... am ...
... Computer am Tisch ...
... deswegen habe sie diese Wäsche werden ...
... und ...
... ja ...
... die anderen ...
... an einer Stichung angegeben ...
... deuten am ersten auf eine ...
... ... Bandscheibe ...
... Vorfall ...
... in einer Servikal-Bandscheibe ...
... oder Servikal-Diskussprolapsus ...
... und aus dem finanziellen Diagnose ...
... die ...
... ähm ...
... mm ...
...ijd ...
... mialgie ...
... äh ...
... und ...
... einchlison ...
... Spondyloarthropatie ...
... äh ...
... und Arthrosin ...
... inhadas ...
... Servikal-Arthrose inbetracht ...
... und ...
äh ...
... zur Weiternaps filters...
...würde ich ...
die Patienten ...
Bei der Klub-Benz Untersuchung werde ich neurologische Zeichen anschauen und beurteilen.
Und diese Hypoesthesie würde ich anschauen.
Von den Patienten werde ich gut abnehmen und die LKG wird geschrieben.
Und gegen den Fass werde ich eine MRT, Servical MRT, veranlassen.
Sollte sich meine Verlachtung beverständlich, werde ich die Patienten Neurosyrogy Abteilung, eine Konzultant,
und stationär aufnehmen und Zugang legen.
Wegen dieser Bechwerden würde ich Schmerzmittel verabreichen.
Natürlich Neurosyrogy oder Neurology, eine Konzultant.
Als bildgebende Maßnahme, was könnte man noch machen?
Außer diese MRT würde ich eine EEG und EMG auch veranlassen.
Bildgebende Verfahren meint ich.
Genau, Bildgebende Verfahren würde ich eine Röntgen, zwei Ebenen in dieser Servical-Bereich auch veranlassen.
Röntgen haben wir jetzt in zwei Ebenen veranlassen.
Genau, wegen dieser Artrosen oder anderen Problemen anschauen und anschauen.
Was könnte man im Röntgen erkennen oder nicht erkennen?
Im Röntgen können wir Tarkoil- und Kalsfikationen anschauen.
Und die Gelenkspaltverrängung des Gelenkspaltes können wir auch anschauen bei dem Röntgen.
Wer auch?
Wie?
Denken Sie, Gelenkspalt.
Ja, genau, bei dieser Servical-Bereich gibt es kein Gelenk.
Ja, doch, Gelenk, das gibt es schon.
Ja, Wertebarspalt, das können wir auch sagen.
Also entweder man sagt Facettengelenken.
Facettengelenken, genau, ja.
Ob der Patient Spondylartrohne oder Facettengelenken.
Ja.
Was kann man noch erkennen?
Das ist kein Gelenk, aber wie ein Gelenk?
Den Bandscheibenfach beurteilen.
Was würde man?
Dort Diskus beurteilen können wir ja.
Genau.
Wie würde es heißen, wenn dieser Diskusfach, dieser Bandscheibenfach sich nicht mehr und krankhaft aussieht?
Wie heißt das?
Wissen Sie?
Osthörschondrose zum Beispiel.
Osthörschondrose, okay.
In general Osthörschondrose ist der Erkrankung des Bandscheibenfaches, der Knochenknopelbereich.
Auch noch sehen, insbesondere in der seitlichen Aufnahme, man kann eine Listese zum Beispiel sehen.
Eine Spondylolis-Tese.
Spondylolis-Tese, okay.
Kann man einen Bandscheibenvorfall im Röntgen sehen?
Eigentlich nicht gut sehen, weil wir weiteilen müssen, weil wir auch beurteilen können,
wenn wir die Bandscheiben für Organen beurteilen können.
Die Aufnahme, genau.
Gut.
Als Differenzialdiagnose könnte man zum Beispiel auch als Ergänzung bei Ihnen,
wenn man die Ausstrahlung in den rechten Arm geht,
ja, einmal ein Bandscheimvorfall kann sein, oder einen Neuroforamen-Stenose.
Kann der Neuroforamen der Kanal sich atrotisch verändert werden?
Kann das enger sein?
Und dadurch kann der Nerf gereizt sein?
Und deswegen kann der Nerf bis zum Daumen Probleme haben.
Wissen Sie zufällig, welches der Matom der Daumen hat?
S6.
Richtig.
Sehr gut.
Und wir können auch als Differenzialdiagnose eine Trasikauter-Zündung erwähnen, oder?
Ja, kann man.
Man kann auch untergelenkt Probleme in den Nacken oder nach unten ziehen, zum Beispiel.
In diesem Bereich könnte man auch Differenzialdiagnose erzählen.
Okay.
Gut.
Was man auf jeden Fall als Diagnose geben kann, was man vergisst,
ist die Diagnose.
Das ist keine Verdachtdiagnose, das kann man schon sagen,
weil der hat Nackenschmerz und Ausstrahlung in den rechten Arm.
Das heißt, Cervico brachialgi.
Ja, Cervico brachialgi.
Der Mensch hat eine Cervico brachialgi rechts,
mit Verdacht auf Cervico hat Bandscheinvorfall.
Das wäre jetzt eine Cervico brachialgi,
mit Verdacht auf Bandscheinvorfall.
C6, wenn man es kennt.
Wenn man den Dermatom kennt, kann man auch sagen,
Cervico brachialgi C6 rechts,
oder man kann auch sagen,
mit Wurzelkompressionssyndrom,
könnte man auch sagen.
Genau, ja, Wurzel.
Irgendetwas, durch Neuroforanzen,
durch Bandscheinvorfall oder durch Spinal,
und so weiter.
Okay.
Aber so genau, müsst ihr das für die Prüfung, glaube ich, nicht wissen.
Das war sehr genau.
Danke schön, danke Ihnen.
Sie haben sehr flüssig gesprochen, das ist gut, finde ich.
Bei Satzbau haben Sie, ich wollte es nicht unterbrochen,
haben Sie manchmal ein bisschen geschnitten,
weil Sie schnell reden,
wollte nicht den Ablauf stören, sozusagen.
Aber ansonsten, gesamt gesehen würde ich sagen,
ich bin nicht der Lehrer, aber würde ich sagen,
haben Sie es geschafft.
Was ist die Prüfung?
Heute habe ich meinen Terminal halten,
Neuzinte, Oktober.
Oktober, oh, wasch.
Noch zwei Wochen, ja.